[Musique]
le défi du jour
essayez de ne pas sourire en voyant ce
chiot qui n'a pas envie de faire de
l'exercice
que ce soit un concert de klaxon pour le
personnel de la santé ou bien une
prestation musicale de balcon on a tous
besoin de ces vidéos qui font du bien
des rayons de soleil dans nos journées
sombres
jimmy boy a créé ce groupe facebook pour
les résidents de newmarket
c'est une collection de vidéos drôles et
de mots d'encouragement son rôle est de
remonter le moral des citoyens
sept employés du service à la clientèle
de la ville a été nommé directeur de la
positivité à newmarket
il y a deux semaines j'ai mis boyle
n'est pas seul newmarket compte aussi 20
ambassadeurs du positivisme des leaders
de la communauté qui aide à leur manière
[Musique]
et qui signale aussi les beaux gestes
des citoyens comme cette dame qui peint
des roches et laissent des mots
d'encouragement partout en ville le
maire de newmarket est à l'origine de ce
mouvement d'optimisme
il a réalisé que ces citoyens allaient
avoir besoin d' aide pendant les longues
semaines d'isolement leur santé mentale
l'inquiétait
[Musique]
les autorités le dise isolement risque
de durer encore longtemps et jimmy boy
est prêt à remonter le moral de
newmarket encore longtemps ici philippe
leblanc radio canada toronto
[Musique]